nation welcome to another edition of the
Evan Carmichael show I'm your host Evan
Carmichael it's fantastic to be back I'm
really excited about the episode we're
talking about how to promote your
business with zero dollars by using the
media I got a great question from one of
my Twitter followers love you guys p for
725 we wrote an essay have you ever done
an episode on press releases are good
way to connect to local media this
defense tax the question I've done a lot
of local prices on a lot of
international press and that's what
helped put me in the spotlight and I
think it's an entrepreneur it's one of
the best ways you can promote your
business so today I'm going to be
sharing my secrets on how to get free
press for your business to help you grow
alright promotion with zero dollars now
you're an expert right at least should
see if you want to have success as an
entrepreneur you better be really good
at what you do and be industry experts
now we're talking about getting to the
media and when reporters are covering
stories guess what they always look for
an expert to comment on it pick up your
daily newspaper we almost any story and
you'll see that an industry expert is
quoted and sharing their opinions why
can't that industry expert be you let's
think about it when you read a magazine
do you pay more attention to the ads if
you pay more attention to the articles
now which one is going to cost you more
running an ad or getting an article
written about you this should be a
no-brainer decision for an entrepreneur
the article you read are much more
visible they don't cost you anything to
get into now the trick is getting on the
radar screens of the media and how you
do it is you start by building a list
now this shouldn't be too hard which
what I do is look at the website all the
trade meetings will cover in your
industry look at other sections of the
major meeting who might run a store by
your industry look at all your local
publications magazines radio shows look
at all the local things happen as well
and
making a list you know in my case I
might target a trade magazine like
entrepreneur I might target a home
business magazine and I might target the
business sections of major media like
New York Times and Wall Street Journal
now I've been in all of those
publications and its really how to
change impact I'm helping me get a
bigger audience and a bigger impact so
you have to start making the list now
when you're making your list the first
thing you want to think about is how to
identify the fit all right step one
build the list and identify the fit you
want to create press releases and expose
yourself to people who / good pics of
what you're an expert at right if I have
a great service for doctors and I'm an
expert in the doctor feels I'm obviously
not going to be targeting the legal
community and the publication towards
lawyers right so you want to make it
really targeted list this doesn't have
to be as hard as people make it out to
be you started making that list and a
quick easy way to do it is just to go to
Wikipedia go to Wikipedia and you can
search for you know I'm in Toronto I
could look for Toronto media outlets you
can look for Quincy Illinois media
outlets and it will show you an entire
list of different media outlets that are
targeted to your city you can look at
the internet public library online you
can look at news and newspapers online
you can look at a new zealand there's
tons of resources online what we want to
find the specific editorial content that
you can be featured in as an expert once
you found that publication you want to
identify the contact who was the person
that you need to get in touch with who's
writing the stories about your industry
so that's the first step right and a lot
of times we use the same email
structured right its first name last
name at the media company com but you
want to start building that list of
everybody who's in your industry whose
locally known to you and who's also
national but covers your specific
segments and make that list of people
that you can connect with I want to get
a quick call in I have Tim on the line
and Jim where are you from and how can I
help good morning i am from colorado
springs colorado well here's the deal is
a tired hermetic but i also have along
the present stand-up comedy
and I have transitioned into doing
public speaking now and so here's that
combined my knowledge of teamwork and
leadership from 30 years as a
firefighter and then present it with
some humor to corporate executives to
help them understand that even though
our lives are at risk every decision we
make what decision-making processes they
use are as difficult as ours but great
presenting or so so the thing is is how
do i market myself more effectively as a
public speaker how do i penetrate
corporations and get their attention you
have a youtube channel 10 yeah sure you
do it are you posting that regularly yes
my lord what is not yet here's the thing
is it's a because I have kind of two
passions my youtube channel is directed
towards the fact that firefighters are
killing themselves in record numbers
because of suicide and alcohol abuse so
my youtube channel is directed more in
that vein as opposed to leadership and
teamwork sorry I'm mixed message know
that mark why not maybe getting the
attention that you need I don't know if
you can work with the speaking house yet
or have a speaking agent or even trying
to get into the some corporations or
early gig they want to see video right
they want to see video of you talking
and a lot of time to people making these
decisions they're searching online right
there looking for you know leadership
speaker or one of the specific messages
that you may tap right whatever your if
you've been comedy common into the
workplace and leadership write comedy
leadership whatever it is people will be
searching those things and right now
you're not coming up and a lot of
speaking gigs that I've done have been
injured some people finding my youtube
channel and their right to me but also
having a popular channel that you're
posting to regularly gives people a
visual sense of you as a speaker right
they want to see hate this guy's
comfortable in front of the camera this
guy as a positive message this is a
message that will probably fit with my
audience and so I would start by posting
regular to your YouTube channel but make
it about what you actually want to speak
about and the fire fighting sucks can
still be there but
put more emphasis on the leadership
stuff that's going to get you the gigs
right right yeah I agree I can do that
so that's like step one right and
creating regular content I put at least
one video a week with your message and
maybe not full I don't know how long a
key notes are you know you don't wanna
do a full half an hour an hour you know
three hour video but quick digestible
tips so take that half an hour
presentation and chunk it down into six
five minute clips so that you know more
content and it's easy to digest because
most people aren't going to sit and
watch a half an hour presentation but
they'll watch something that I binding
it on one to dip a copy and then the
watch another another and another and
that's that's what you want you want
people to get hooked right well I'm i
can probably i did a TEDx talk so i
could probably use that as well yeah you
can definitely link to that TEDx is a
great opportunity I link to that from
your channel but then you know even
people from Ted act so if you have a
great TEDx talk people will then look
for your name right some of the great
speakers on tedactive if they're moved
by what you are saying they'll look for
your name and so what's going to come up
and if they see Oh Tim they found your
YouTube channel and all you're talking
about is firefighter stuff they may feel
like aldus this is not really relevant
to what I need in my corporation I get
it yeah can I do to youtube channels or
should I refine a single channel that I
have I mean is it possible up to yeah
you can all you need for YouTube does
have a different gmail address um cuz
I'm a big fan you love mixing it yeah
you know I would want people to know
your fire fire background with want
people to know that you probably care
about firefighters and helping them you
know not kill themselves and these are
heroes of America you know I think that
makes you different I know i'll put my
content maybe it's if you learn to focus
on leadership sauce maybe it's you know
75% gear towards that and twenty-five
percent geared towards the firefighters
and problems up to you your judgment
call but I don't think that if you do
that properly I don't think there's that
the tracks from your public speaking gig
I think it will actually help you
excellent I can do that bro I'm excited
for you okay now can I be were talking
just you were just talking about press
rude
and that sort of thing is it is it worth
it to to generate a press release about
that sort of you know I could I could
the question I have is is talking about
firefighters suicide and that sort of
thing a new press releases geared
towards that yeah so what I would view
if I were you since you were a public
speaker and you have that gift in front
of the camera in front of an audience
that a lot of people may not have if
something that's touching your heart you
know something is there's something you
really want to get out I would make a
video about it and then we chose our
reporters that are talking about that
issue so if there's something that comes
up in the media some something big
relating to firefighters I would make a
video about that and then send that off
to the media and say I'm willing to be
an expert answer any questions cool all
right thanks man we gotta keep on moving
but I appreciate the call thanks sir now
the first second I talked about making a
list so we're finding all the people
that are related to our industry that
are writing stories about your industry
or your local environment that you can
potentially reach out to next step
before you reach out to them okay I know
your your gun holds you want to reach
out to them the next step though before
you decided to create a media page takes
reporters don't like working typically
with new sources one because it takes
more work to find them and two it's hard
to tell what they're saying is true or
not it's hard to tell that person is
actually expert or not there's a lot
more vetting more work involved so you
can reduce that if you create a great
media page for them they don't want you
to make them look bad because you don't
really know what you're talking about so
on this media page what I want you to do
is highlight your professional
background showcase any media
experiences that you've already had if
you haven't done anything yet you can
start with the smaller and local
publications usually pretty easy to get
into them and what that does is see a
lot of the media's they don't like to be
the first right it's hard to go straight
to the wall street journal but if they
see that you've already put in other
media publications it's much easier to
say yes so you want to show how long you
been in business what clients who work
with what professional designations you
have anything to show your credibility
you want to put on that media page
anything that shows you know what you're
talking about and that you're not going
to waste their time it also helps to
have a really professional picture of
yourself and opinion on what your your
industry is you want to show you in
action so we're looking at 10 with
stand-up comedian / speaker he could
have him has a head shot and then also
him being on stage to him actually in
action so you want to have that up there
as well as the quick bio a hundred-word
biol about yourself that when you're
reaching out to these reporters they
have a quick sense of who you are and
that yes you know what you're talking
about okay create that media page I
wanna get to the call I've got Sasha on
the line Sasha where are you from and
how can I help hey i'm in orlando I'm an
author me my full name is Sasha Hansen's
I via look me up we should be able to
see like my children books that i right
and I want to know how to kind of get I
guess more publicity as far as not just
being a children's book author but also
be able to I guess give advice I'm like
raising children because i have three
three sons ages 4 5 and 8 and i write
the book based on my three signs and the
characters in the book like exactly like
my children and myself so yeah I kind of
want to branch out into that area kind
of like what you were talking about i
guess just a few moments few moments ago
I guess about setting up the pages and
everything but is there anything like
more I can do to kind of like connect my
book with you know like with moms and
you know give out advice and stuff like
that this is look how to is it
nonfiction or is it a fictional story I
don't know it's all fictional children's
books it will send my fiction it is
based on like i said before based on my
kids but of course you know since its
children's book we have to like you know
elaborate a lot of things and you know
make everything bigger than live to keep
the children interested but yeah it
really is based on my my children it's
for kids ages i'd say like maybe carita
and so yeah okay so you have now a
branding challenge where a lot of author
they'll write a book to help give
themselves more exposure and hey I'm the
exit look I wrote this book but but
having a book that's not necessarily how
to a little more fiction you know it's
hard to see a Stephen King being an
expert on something other than writing
in his book so that's a challenge that
you now have to create in creating your
own personal brand and starting to share
your thoughts and opinions right so
first of all figured out what is it that
you stand for what are the main
components of your belief system of how
kids can be raised and how life could be
easier for young parents who are looking
after their kids and kind of similar
situation with you and once you figure
out what your platform is then it's
spreading it so you're looking at social
media you looking at guest guest posts
on famous sites and you're looking at
usual media traditional media like we've
been talking about already today so I'd
be building up a personal brand around
yourself your name right isin with you
have Sasha handsome column but if it's
available I Hansen and the low my book
series is called the wide brothers and
my most recent book is called waiting
the number for baby and the letter y as
in yes because all my sons names start
with the letter Y and so yeah it's
waiting for baby why it's about when I
was pregnant with my last night my
youngest son and you know how the big
brothers have to wait for their new
brother to come right so I'll be
creating my own website now your own
personal domain name and showing
yourself as an expert and then starting
to share your thought so however you
best communicate you know if you'd like
to write since you're over to your
writer then you can write blog posts and
you can then take that to Twitter and
short form if you like to do videos and
you can create a YouTube channel right
if you'd like to create pictures you can
put it on Facebook but starting to put
your thoughts out there so people know
who you are what you're all about that
you can funnel some of your existing
readers to but then also reach out to
the media who is covering these issues
with it their stories about kids and
families and how to parents and advice
in every major publication every single
day of the year and that could be you
being an expert
publication but if you reach out to you
know whoever it is you eat just in New
York Times today hey I have this great
idea for you and there's no all you can
say hey I've written this fiction book
it's a lot harder to get their attention
then if you have a personal branded
website you're showcasing yourself as an
expert you can say you're the author of
three books and potentially more coming
that really helps establish yourself
more as a credible source but they would
want to use an autopsy us also helps
your book sales right Ellie I will start
starting to build your personal brand
starting to create some content that you
can posted to your blogs and social
media and then reaching out to media
publications to get notice then and have
them feature you in your opinion which
one would you think would probably be
the most successful I was considering
like I said like the YouTube you know
trying to like maybe give advice every
day or something and then like have like
a little link to my books or whatever or
or like a blog or something like that I
mean I'm sorry blogs as much or they
just want to watch videos like I'm gonna
decide like which one is like would be
more profitable right now I would
default to wherever you feel your
strongest I love you too YouTube is my
number one social media platform you
know getting half a million views a
month on the channel and it's driving a
lot of business for me but I love I'm
okay being on camera I love doing the
Q&A answering people's questions if you
are uncomfortable in front of the camera
and you don't like it and you don't want
to learn that skill and you feel you're
much better as a writer then then right
right like I don't like writing it's not
something that I love doing so if you
love right in your hate video then I
would default to doing a blog and then
trying to do guest blog posts on other
people's blogs and doing short form
content like on Twitter will vary
written but if you love doing a video
and you want to learn that skilled and
gold video so there's no one right
answer people having success everywhere
it's more figuring out what is core to
you and where you feel your strength
really lives we gotta move on since you
Sasha for the question for calling in
today's you're talking about how to get
free media attention and publicity to
promote your business and take it where
you want to go so we set it off number
one is you got to make that list make a
list of media or potential targets for
you number two before you reach out you
got to make immediate page the showcases
all your expertise and showcases that
you know what you're talking about so
they're not making a mistake I haven't
you want next step is you got to pick a
topic so sup number three is you gotta
pick a topic that they care about this
is where most entrepreneurs make a huge
estate because what you do is you feel
why and you send out an information
about yourself right you send out
something promotional something that
most press releases look alike and
people don't care most personally would
get thrown in the garbage because it's
too self-promotional you have to think
about the publication that you're
reaching out to and what their audience
was actually care about so if we look
back at Sasha such a she's the author
right she has her kids book line if she
went on and sort of reaching out to the
New York Times and said hey I've just
watched this new book can you feature it
she's probably going to get a quick know
and that she's trying a response because
it's super emotional but if she reached
out and said something like I've got ten
tips for how young mothers can prepare
their family for a new baby something
like that right that's more interesting
right that's a little more feeling that
something that might actually appear in
New York Times and that's what you want
to think about right that publication
are you going after think about the
story that actually appeared there and
then give them a topic that's similar to
that right you don't see publications
about a new book release about babies
right no we're going to care about that
so that's going to really increase your
chances of getting it so pick a really
strong talk now when you're creating
your freshly you want to reach out your
book components with six components
number one is a strong headline right
you want to capture them with a really
strong headline something meaningful
something with punched a great way to do
it is how to a top ten mistakes to avoid
something really headline e that that
captures attention number two is the
compelling second headlines so
a strong / deadline and then another
headline underneath so if you don't
catch it with the first one the second
one is also really meaningful and
powerful I've used it strategy over and
over and over again it's gotten me into
New York Times and Wall Street Journal
in forbes magazine really targeted to
what I'm trying to reach and so guys is
worse for you number three you're
including the location in the dates
right that they said is coming out and
the location where you are then the
number four is the body and this is
where you're explaining the problem
deepen your solutions quote yourself as
an expert right try to write a story
like they would actually publish it I've
had publications take just my press
release and copy and paste it and
publish it adds is because it was
written like a story that's what you
want to do write it like a story hold
yourself like an expert exactly like you
see it if you take that article from the
New York Times it's constantly published
over and over and over again and you
copy that format and that's what you
send them as the press release you're
much more likely to get approved okay
that's number four number five in your
100 word biol write about yourself and
100 words keep it short keep it sweet
keep it meaningful even impactful we're
going to link to your immediate page in
there as well for more information but
get your bio downs 100 words so I can
quickly digest who it is that you are I
don't want pages and pages and pages
just enough to tease me to wire learn
more and the number six is the contact
information all right how do they reach
you you have your media page you have
your phone number you have an email
address okay so that's how we put it all
together a strong headline a strong
second headline the location and date
the body here your press release where
you're copying an existing story format
your 100 word bio under your contact
information okay it works guys I promise
you that work that uses over and over
and over and over again and I want to
see you have success getting to the
media I have Nadine on the line mckean
where are you from and how can I help hi
I'm calling from Toledo I just generated
a small cleaning business and one of my
main concerns I guess you kind of
covered bases already and what do you
suggest is a greater network flow or a
plug to obtain morsel contractual work
for
like return residential work like where
do we go to get it what do you suggest
we have to do to get it because I by
myself continuously coming out of
expenses such as for advertisement and
things of that nature and I'm just
trying to find some type of format where
I can take advantage more so of free
advertising versus continuously coming
out you know spitting expenses are not
making the money to cover it as well so
that's where I'm stuck at right now yeah
cool the two things I would look at is
one really local because your cleaning
business you know somebody calls you up
from New York City you're not going to
go up there and clean their place so you
got to do highly targeted local and it's
not just a lot easier to get into those
local publications newspapers magazines
because there's not as much demand to
get in and I try to think what's an
angle right is there something positive
that you're trying to do in the
community is there something really new
and exciting about your cleaning service
that hasn't been done before are you
trying to put you know Toledo on the map
you've got some big vision something
that story worthy it's a lot easier to
get into a local publication than it
would be to get into wall street journal
so I be just try think about local
publications and an interesting hawk and
interesting angle something that you're
doing differently or something that you
staying for that you know you think
could really inspire the community and
that's how you can reach out and and
again much higher chance of getting in
the other thing I would look at there
was also partnerships you know who can
you what other businesses can you ally
yourself with that could make referrals
and introductions for you so you're not
trying to get one business at a time at
a time at a time but you get a constant
flow of new business coming in because
of the Alliance's that you've made
having main give any aligned to the
partnerships there's anybody coming to
mind might be a good fit well I just
established a kind of ship with a friend
and the reason why I chose to deal with
her per se was because of the fact that
she had made a [ __ ] in the past and I
guess I hurt for whatever her situation
was it didn't work out like it should
have said she lost the bid she's doing
something more so with like LM a chain
which is are like a
Lucas County Metropolitan you know
low-income housing she had a [ __ ] for
janitorial services for like over five
year but she technically was not the
owner of the business at the time so I
guess due to the contract in once
whoever was the owner seen that she had
the capabilities of getting those [ __ ]
they demean it money cuz they were in
the sellers of business they demanded
money up front versus actually getting
the money within got five year period
that they discussed in the contract so
that didn't go out for us so I'm not
going to class team with her and you
know trying to work something out with
her okay so that's one right that's
great I mean to see what happens that
one person now you want to think how do
I get 20 of these people right how do I
get 20 people who are ideally in
business but not in your business
they're in a complementary business so
who try to think about what businesses
these companies are buying from before
they buy from you so before any cleaning
services so if I'm manufacture right I
make I make tables and I need cleaning
services before I by cleaning services
who else am i buying from that's not
related to actual cleaning services
right and those are potential alliance
partners for you not my partners in your
business not like you're giving them a
cod when you're doing 50 50 or anything
like that just they could refer you on
those are the types of businesses you
want to start making alliances with so
that when they're talking to the
manufacturers and they know they have a
cleaning problem they can pass on your
name so when you say building these
alliances are you suggesting more so
network because when you say that right
now I'm thinking like okay well what do
I have to offer them you know I mean for
me to get that benefit so I guess so
that's why I'm stuck do you juggle I'm
networking with these people or some
kind of trust I can imagine yeah and you
could potentially help refer them to
write when you're both dealing with the
same kind of clients and you want to
help each other out and some you know
some people might be really specific and
really clear here you got to give me a
lead if I'm giving you lead but most
people to develop a friendly
relationship with them you may be the
first cleaner who's ever
to them and now you're on the radar and
you know you're on their radar too and
then you could potentially refer them
into your client if you see that there's
a need that they have right if you're
working with a client and you see that
they have a really desperate need for
another type of service that you don't
offer but you know that there's somebody
else who does it you passing on the
president's name makes you look better
right it's a good move for you it helps
build that relationship and your help
and solve the clients problems so a lot
of it is just helping each other out
you're both targeting the same kind of
clients with different products and
services and you can reach for each
other in when the opportunity arises so
that's good you know good start and it's
easy to set up those calls and those
relationships to say hey here's what i'm
doing i'm targeting same kinds as you
i'd love to have a quick coffee to
subscribe how we might be able to work
together and you'll find some people
love it and they're on board and and now
you're on the radar screen and they may
be able to give you referrals and some
people won't and that's part of the game
shout okay we gotta keep it one but
thank you so much for calling in yeah so
use the medium and that's it that's the
topic for today is getting in the media
and how to get local price especially
for of local business you want to get to
that local media but then also it's not
the only way to grow a business right I
love missing partnerships it's a
fantastic way to build a relationship
and again instead of just selling to one
person one person one person a time but
if you like really big grind you've got
people giving you a steady flow of
business now we're ready to reach out
okay now you're ready to reach out you
have the list you have an engine
everything set up you reach out and you
pitch yourself I want to just close the
show and give me some ninja resources
that i use to help me get more media the
first one is called PR leaves and what
this is a service that reporters are
subscribing to and every day they
release new stories and its reporters
saying I'm working on this story and I
need an expert here's my deadline here's
an overview of what I need and you have
a rapport with contact information those
are those are guineas right if there's
anything related to what you're doing in
there you have a reporter saying I'm
looking
for expert I'm looking for help please
help me right that's so much easier than
having to do all the research yourself
now this one isn't free it's ninety nine
dollars a month I've used it to get into
the New York Times and other huge
publication so that'll worth it check it
out the other one that I use is Fame bit
and that's the different for YouTube
where you can partner up with other
youtubers and do collaborations where
they feature you on their channel and
you get featured on their channel so
start reaching out guys because getting
into the media and getting that
publicity to really make a difference
for you in your businesses here and
helping to take off I've got time for
one last caller I have Stacey on the
line Stacey where are you from and how
can I help hey I am so McLean Virginia
and I'm a little bit leery of social
media so I have to get past that what my
question was to you though was how can a
small business person get like grants or
reconstruction loans I have a historic
building that I need to be repaired on
and I was wondering if there's any way I
could get some help with that so a lot
of times the great question grants are
definitely available it depends on your
area and often it's down to the city
level so he'll be state grants under big
city grants and the grants are often for
very specific things so you could get a
grant as a woman entrepreneur you can
get a grant to restore a heritage
building right so they're really
targeting really specific what I look
for is a combination of the website to
look at the state websites and look at
the city website and any city resources
I don't know what in your local area of
you know the city that you're in go in
and talk to them and say hey I need help
finding the right square in to help me
out with this grass look great because
you have to pay it back right you get
money to do this thing and you don't
have to pay back so everybody likes free
money for the down sides always that it
can take a long
hi when you're dealing with the
government it can take a long time and
as entrepreneurs you know we want things
to happen yesterday we're faster
automated we're excited and the
government can just drag you out oh you
got an estimation and it all becomes a
you know a part-time job like doing
these grants and so is it worth the time
and effort for you to put into making
that happen oh I really appreciate the
lead in the direction I'm going to i'ma
start researching that right now you're
home right are you looking to raise god
I would love to get about a hundred
grand to do it because my fiance before
he died he started the rid of its a
hundred year old building it was build
in the 1900s beautiful historic building
he started the renovations on the first
floor and the second and the third he
renovated the first and he died right
before he could finish the second in the
third so I need a new roof on there I
would love to get new windows put in
there I would love to finish the
renovation I was able to get Edward
Jones in the in the first floor and
they're coming in and they're doing like
thirty thousand dollars worth of
renovations on the building so I'm yeah
it's I was awesome so I mean that's high
on the grand side you know that's a high
amount asked for and and you know what
when you go and you research the grand
they're often for a certain amount right
so say you know aggressor up to X amount
of dollars and tells you you don't want
to be asking beyond it because they're
not going to you can see that's that's
their cap the things that you have to
make sure this is this is something my
government looks at that no other source
will really care about they want to see
the impact that it's going to have on
the community they want to see that by
investing into this you're going to make
your city or if it's Virginian you're
going to make Virginia if it's at stake
better right if you go any talk to an
angel investor or a venture capitalist
they don't care you talk to a bank they
don't care if you're making Virginia
better or not
just one of the kids are getting the
money back so while the government oh
that's that's what they're in business
to do right in to help help their city
help their state so you have to make
sure when you're talking about your
proposal and when you're going in having
the meetings and having those phone
calls that you have a clear plan of how
going to make the fitting of the state
you are brilliant thank you thank you
thank you so much because not only did
you give me a path to go to but you got
it me down the right Avenue so I know
who to talk to and I know how to drop my
letter and I think it's going to be a
win-win I think I really do i'm really
excited I'm so glad I call there well
the other pocket I would look at is also
private right if you got Edward Jones
that come in and they're putting 30
change is a building that's like the
hardest part is getting the first one if
that's your plan and you have three
stories and you want to get you know to
13 sold that that may be an avenue to is
to go talk to other corporations and say
hey do you guys want the tech employer
the third floor and they might be
willing to invest showing that somebody
is already done it helps reduce the risk
nobody want to do the first one that's
the hardest one you already got the
first one so that's like what yeah we
took them out of that the commercial
real estate and put them on mainstream
and my real estate guys like you need to
be on Main Street that's the historic
part that's what everybody is and they
change their business plans like yeah
you know you like listen you know the
way we should and they did it and they
liked the idea so worried Lori so one
more thing now a station I'd your
proposal you know Edward Jones is a
brand name right it's not just mom and
pop you know I quite nice towards the
brand name and if they were willing to
move their corporate office from a
corporate setting to be on Main Street I
would use that in my proposal I would
have them come on to and say hey we
think this is a really historic area
that's why we're investing and you
should too so you have use their brand
name to help you get your grant to well
girl oh my god I love you I
I wouldn't to none in my friend okay
thank you all right good luck with your
plan hey everybody listening in the more
momentum you can show the more
likelihood you're going to get the
results that you want listen we've got
another great show in the books I can't
believe how fast these shows don't go I
want to give a big shout out to my
producers Daniela and Josh you guys
rocks demand the shifter me and brought
on amazing collars you had a great time
we helped a lot of on sprayer today I'm
going to be back on soon stay tuned
until then teach me to believe and
updating guys take care